people think doubt is here when you if
you ever experience the the psychology
of doubt you don't feel it here it's not
like oh my head is hurting you forget it
here
in your chest that anxiety
right you feel the butterflies oh my God
is Islam the true oh maybe I did the
wrong thing maybe it's the wrong choice
oh look what he said oh then you just
click click click click click he Hearts
to the point where you become numb and
you're like why the heck am I even a
Muslim damn I'm shooting Wilson I was
questioning my faith man I was I was
thinking I should leave this now it was
like a seed that was planted in my mind
that grew very deep
and
even if I refute in that seed doubt was
still there like let's say I would
answer it I wouldn't and that's why I
find it's like it's obsessive you know
it's compulsive it's intrusive and I
believe obviously shaytan he'll push it
because like I've answered that doubt
intellectually and that's why this is
not just an intellectual thing people
need to understand it's not just an
intellectual thing and I just and I
couldn't get rid of the feeling what if
I'm wrong what if Islam is wrong what if
I made the wrong choice
before we go on
um huge welcome guys smash the like
button right now subscribe
um comment tell the algorithm and
inshallah we'll go into we'll start the
Gabriel's story all right
you're in River as well
foreign
we want to talk about the story of how I
became Muslim but the context of this
yeah the struggle
a lot
first year
was I had this convert Zeal I was very
pumped up there's a lot of you know it's
a lot of
yakin like I really felt like man this
is a you know really I know what I've
done what's what's converts you can't
wait zeros like
hmm
I think it's it's a psychological
need to belong to something to a group
and you get motivated by belonging to
the group being accepted realizing that
you've discovered something new you're
coming maybe from a position of Doubt
weakness and all of a sudden you've make
you made a realization wow this is how
life is or this is the truth the way you
perceive it it gives you this the
strength this mental physical emotional
strength
it's hard to explain it's very abstract
but you just have this extra energy that
pushes you to do things that you
wouldn't otherwise do
for example for me I was coming from a
bit of a depressed
background at that time when I was
looking for a truth
um Identity Crisis coming from Romania
to Canada different culture
also at that time I didn't convert from
Christianity to Islam I left
Christianity
very agnostic yeah so what happened is
through just being exposed to different
information and talking to different
people I realized that Christianity was
not the truth
so but I didn't switch to Islam I just
knew that this is not the truth that
caused an identity crisis because I was
like you know you're
for us anyway
Romanians it's like that's your that is
your identity religion is your identity
whether people practice or not it's a
different story like you are Christian
that's it you know everything your
history your ancestry everything started
but a lot of people are ignorant about
what Christianity is
and
back in the days like when I grew up in
the 80s
you didn't have access to the internet
into formation the way you do today
so we pretty much like that's the only
truth you know
and your existence is somewhat tied to
that your identity or even your
confidence
so once I was exposed to more
information internet had access to like
libraries
I started talking to different people
just being exposed to different cultures
man like I mean we always thought that
Islam is bad Muslims are bad and you
meet Muslims you're like oh they're not
like that wait a second so there's a
contradiction there you start wondering
like who's right who's wrong
so my people are saying Muslims are bad
but you're a nice Muslim
so wait a second like what's going on
here
so there's that cognitive dissonance
right
and that pushes you to to ask more so
ask those questions realize Christianity
is not the right thing left it
but leaving that next question like what
am I right I mean I you still the way
Allah created is like you need to have
a way
you're talking in something yeah you
have to I mean that's that's that's part
of so people find a way in I don't know
spirituality Buddhism Hinduism you find
all kinds of people going to because
it's it's in your brain you're wired
that way right they call The God Spot
right that's one of the things that's
they've there was an article that they
discovered this part of the brain that
gets uh when under a scan it's active
when they experience uh spiritual
uh you know experiences
so human beings are that's the fitra I
mean they were wired to believe in a
higher being now people call it
different things people say Spirit of
the forest ancestors blah blah blah what
not but in the end everyone has some
form of belief
it's just the way we are wired so with
regards to the convert just when I
convert it
when people convert around people like
you have this strength where you feel
like man I'm finally coming from that
background where I don't know anymore
I'm confused I'm in doubt coming into
the light
making a realization that well this is
it
just I don't know you feel like it's
hard to explain bro no I get it bro it's
like when you go to university for
example right like let's say when we
when we went to McMaster University for
undergrad like we have people coming
from everywhere bro just like reverse
right we have people coming from Toronto
Mississauga Brampton Windsor Waterloo
Sarnia literally all over I'm turning
even internationally bro but during
first week first week of University
everyone was wearing the McMaster
hoodies everyone was wearing the
McMaster sweatshirts why it gives them a
sense of belongingness and we as human
beings we love that belongingness so
then they would speak in a specific way
they would chant the same cheers you
know it's almost like there's an
identity there's a community there so
that's what you mean yeah and it goes to
an extent subhanallah goes to extremes
to show
the
how how deep this goes psychologically
so belonging to for example a football
team soccer whatever I mean people are
willing to kill for that yeah and they
kill each other okay tattoos or tattoos
yeah you brand yourself a lot of people
I mean sometimes you just want to show
them I'm here to stay I'm gonna tattoo
myself in this way because this is my
way you know loyalty right even though
it might not be there but it's a it's an
act of signal it's a signal right
so people do all kinds of things and
with time though it kind of settles
slowly I think people realize
um they have different challenges and
naturally you you you kind of settle in
the in the the the level that you should
be in and some people fall below that
right but I would say that if you are in
the truth
then you'll realize okay this is the
level that I need to be at the optimal
level
um if you're not people fall out like
okay football teams people fall out
belonging to a certain Club people fall
out
um
people practicing certain ideologies or
religions they'll fall out like if you
actually look at it
how do they respect the tenants of that
system or whatever it's kind of like a
pick and choose you know it's just
enough for them to feel like okay I'm
doing something and most reverts
actually go through this they do they do
I would say they do and there's reasons
for that and we can talk about it a lot
so yeah even with Islam like people will
fall out of it if they're not taken care
of if they don't themselves
take care of themselves in terms of
knowledge practice and so on so I would
say first first five years are critical
or if people think first year first few
months now it's like first five years
until you internalize till it becomes
your identity
and it's not like okay today my it's
become my identity it's a process so
you're internalizing the identity yeah
it's it's I'm not I'm not a I'm not a
Romanian Muslim I'm just a Muslim you
know what I mean it's nothing to do with
my ethnicity I'm Muslim it doesn't
matter what nationality it doesn't
matter what food I eat or what clothing
I wear I mean obviously should be within
the Sharia but
it doesn't matter you know like I'm just
I'm a Muslim I'm I'm a Latino Muslim I'm
a black Muslim I'm a whatever I am a
Muslim doesn't matter you know but it
takes time and this happened to you yeah
of course so first you felt that okay
I found the truth you're going there
you're doing you know waking up in the
morning pushing shoving you're tough
right you're trying to do every girl on
your beard for you you're right you're
trying to do everything right and
um
um
I would say it's
it's a test
it's
um Allah says
do people think they'll be left to
believe that or to say that we believe
and they will not be actually it's like
they'll be put in a fitna a test a
specific test
right when we say fitna right people
think Fitness we're talking about women
or something like that no fitna is like
it's it's a it's a specific trial that a
person goes through
um
and it's not enough to just say yeah
Muslim like Allah will test you are you
it's not that Allah doesn't know whether
you're sincere or not because Allah
say uh
for Allah to show
whether you're
a truth a truthful truth people convert
to Islam because they think it's cool
it's trending sometimes right yeah like
if you hear a lot of agitates saying
this is Haram you know like well you're
finished oh that's not the one
foreign
sisters you know who have oh the hijab
is cool you know it's like it's like a
symbol of I don't know what empowerment
empowerment yeah modesty and so on and
or people just love Arabic and the
Arabic culture and then they convert but
is it these are colored and all this
yeah is it really Islam and people you
know take for example
Nation of Islam the movement was a
reactionary movement to racist racism
and slavery and white Superior Supremacy
and
if you look at the Theology of it was
that it's the oppositional black men are
Divine they are a God and white man is
the devil
right this is you know it taught black
men to believe that they're not just
Superior or equal to I meant but that
they are divine
and then it went to the next point that
God is black or a black man and so on
obviously things that's funny when you
feel uncomfortable just talk about
but it's a reality
but do you see that if you look at the
Nation of Islam movement
look at the discipline and the Zeal that
they have oh man right because it gave
them a purpose and it unified them
that's kind of what happens with with a
lot of the Commerce they come in they
have to see up they push right they're
coming from a struggle and it gives them
a purpose so that purpose is very
powerful now you can maintain that
purpose and nurture that purpose
sculpt that purpose by following the
Sharia and specific things that we're
going to talk about inshallah how to
deal with new Muslims and so on
especially at the beginning
or you're gonna
go up naturally
and then slowly or fall down right
because there's no way you can maintain
the wind bro it's just no way it's it's
impossible
okay if you're not gonna do the things
they have to do and even if you do it
right our Believers that Iman goes up
and down this is known it's known what
is it dependent on it depends on your
actions your sins and so on right you
you commit sins which everyone does
everyone commit sins bro go down
you do something good you feel good
right I'm sure that when we're together
right now we feel different when we're
alone man yeah no one is gonna you know
and that's why it's so important and
people say no I'd rather chill with you
Brothers than than be alone
that's no one there are Dean you know
it's like said that the shinta will come
for the lone person alone sheep we know
it's not we're not making things up
so
it kind of
goes down and
um some people are able to do the things
that they need to do in terms of
knowledge practice
or get support as well which is a huge
thing to get support and community and
some people don't so then they go down
some people leave and so on and not to
mention of course in this very sensitive
equation
you have
shaytan okay who's very unhappy that
you've left whatever lifestyle you've
had and you've come to the truth
from the Gin that we've talked about in
previous episode in the Gin plus from
the human beings
in the form of I don't know Apostles
these are devils right
these are devils because Allah says
from Jinn and from human beings
[Music]
right like the Wasa of Doubt word is
doubt doubt people think doubt is here
when you if you ever experience that
the psychology of doubt you don't feel
it here it's not like oh my head is
hurting you forget it here
in your chest that anxiety
right you feel the butterflies oh my God
is Islam the truth oh maybe I did the
wrong thing maybe it's the wrong choice
oh look what he said oh then you just
click click click click click he Hearts
to the point where you become numb and
you're like why the heck am I even a
Muslim
important bro since you go through
something similar yeah bro I was like
literally I mean I was questioning my
faith man
I was I was thinking I should leave this
now not me only people that I've worked
with I mean at that time
I was working with non with new Muslims
I just got pulled in like they saw your
Newsome
you come we we have you know this group
of new Muslims you got to work with them
but they didn't understand the struggles
I was experienced the same thing maybe
worse than them and I'm hearing them
doubting and talking about I want to
leave Islam or leaving Islam I had
friends who have left Islam
and then in my inside of me I'm also
doubting and struggling right
and it's like an OCD
like an obsessive compulsive
you know disorder with intrusive
thoughts like can I control your mind
sometimes you know kind of
you've listened to the wrong thing or
something has come into your mind you
just can't get rid of it and it just
snowballs no ball snowball snowball and
if you can't open about it to anyone you
can ask anyone you don't have any
support you don't have knowledge and
that's the reality most new Muslims
don't have knowledge normal
right that's why Islam I think a lot of
people need to understand
when we talk about Islam
I say this a lot when I deal with
women's issues women will be like uh you
know well in Islam like we just get
thrown to the side we get divorced right
I'm like no it's not like that because
see Islam is supposed to be practiced
within a an Islamic framework
we're talking whenever we're talking
about Sharia in today's context in
Canada the UK wherever we are
even in Muslim countries we're talking
about like
Islam
not in its home field yeah in a
non-muslim context even it's an
anonymous it's like
it's like an operating system that's
like you know it's like putting Mac on
Windows you know yeah like you can power
it up it might work here and there it's
not it's not optimized
so a lot of the questions that people
have in doubts are like oh uh could we
as a Muslim woman if I get divorced I
just get thrown in the street what kind
of Islam is this you know a lot of
doubts come like that like no sister but
I don't have a family I don't have a
father I don't have anyone yeah but in
Islamic you would have the Amir you
would have the whole Community is
responsible to take care of and they
would right but you see we don't have
that because we're not in that Paradigm
right so the same thing with new Muslims
within the Islamic Paradigm they'll be
protected from these Downs that's why
the the show they are so strict on some
of these apostate behaviors or what they
do right it's not that okay people just
leave Islam No Hadith says and they go
against the community right and even in
the Quran Allah writes they believe then
they disbelieve and they believe again
then they disbelieve again and then they
go deeper into their disbelief yes so
it's such a it's such a it's
psychologically so taxing it can cause
so much mental health issues so Islam
protects you especially the new Muslims
so what did you do what did you do when
you bro I mean to be honest
it was just the blessing of all like I
talked to one of my friends uh he's an
Italian brother it's interesting story
and what happened to him because he left
Isla like two or three times that's the
problem and he came back yeah but that's
what we always say we're like man we
only it's only Allah that kept the sin
man like this I can't see anything that
I've done I mean we can talk about
certain things but even then it's like
when Allah says
you know uh in Allah like Allah guides
whom he was indeed the guys whom he was
like period you know right people say oh
we got a lot of guys when we was who
this yeah who deserves Allah knows best
you know but really it's like Allah
guides whom he was I don't know why and
how
of course we don't know what Allah
wants but right
really if I look back at it if he looks
I mean this guy like left Islam bro he
became like Shia he became like I don't
know why he became Christian again like
he went man oh God you know I mean Allah
what did you and this brother
specifically like what are some things
you did too because we still want to
give some practical stuff yeah no doubt
no doubt
um I would say like if I were to let's
just rewind entering Islam getting over
the uh
that convert CEO like I remember man I
was like I was flying you know I felt so
good I was like man this is it you know
motivated bro
sleep like three four hours wake up pray
fast push you feel just the Brotherhood
you feel new you know
even those it was difficult
to explain to friends and family and so
on it was a lot of Shame
you know it was it was I felt
embarrassed to be honest but when I
became assumed like I was embarrassed
you know like girls would see me
trying to hug me I'm like you know it
was weird man like God it was just it
was so I felt shame I would hide my
books on my pillow
you know I wouldn't tell my brother man
or like you know my mom at the beginning
you know she didn't know
and even like if they'll catch me
I could say I'm just reading something
but I felt embarrassed I don't know why
stuff
yeah uni you know you you saw those
memes bro where it's like the the
revert's mom is knocking on his door
yeah it's like yo he's like praying he's
like yo what are you doing he's like
drugs
because God forbid you know prayer is
worse than drugs I don't know if
anything would it was not with them bro
it was me with me internal internal and
but I felt good when I was around the
brothers I felt motivated and indeed
that for some time that shame
disappeared to the point so I went to
the next level where I was like fighting
with people debating like I just wanted
to fight with everyone you're wrong
you know you're wrong you're out let's
go to church and talk to people let's go
to you know we would wait outside for
like
you're
finished
we would go like outside the bar and
wait like to see if Muslims are going
inside and we're like no yo come here
it's all right bro you know like that
yeah like we're so like pumped up right
and one day
one day
someone
trying to understand exactly what
happened but it was just a doubt that
came into my mind from one of these
these idiots
right on YouTube
yeah I mean
I think it was on YouTube or it was
through one of the meetings
and
it it was like a seed that was planted
in my mind that grew very deep
and
even if I refute in that seed doubt was
still there like let's say I would
answer it I wouldn't and that's why I
find it's like it's obsessive
you know it's compulsive it's intrusive
and I believe obviously shaytan he'll
push it because like I've answered that
doubt intellectually and that's why
this is not just an intellectual thing
people need to understand it's not just
an intellectual thing
and I just and I couldn't get rid of the
feeling what if I'm wrong what if Islam
is wrong
what if I made the wrong choice what if
what if what if all these ifs just
putting that in there
um and I couldn't get rid of and around
me people are leaving Islam people
aren't having doubts these guys at that
time it was very aggressive
and that's when I started my YouTube
channel my YouTube channel
was started in response to my doubts
like I wanted to literally research and
review myself like a lot of the work
that I've done was to work on myself
actually
um you know what I mean and then it
could have started like we wrote like
hundreds of Articles like researched
articles right
um we spent a lot of time on that but a
lot of it was like my doubts and our
doubts as you know like me another
brother
and
and so you know you go from one thing
and answer it another thing answer
another
another and still it's like okay answer
the hundreds still you're not able to
say look man that's it you know like
come on like how many things you're
gonna answer this is the truth
because
doubts are very very dangerous so
Scholars say that what's more what's
worse is it
like it's a a desire to say the doubt
because that leads to cover you know it
can really
and subhanallah some of the thoughts
that you get in your mind are indeed
like
could be cover you know I remember
sitting in bed laying down in bed at
night
and so weird man this you know it's just
my mind's working like literally I can't
stop what if it's not true what if this
what if that whatever
and
all of a sudden like little lightning
hit next to my window bro like it was
such a like I felt the energy that it
was like you know enlightening strikes
it's like energy in the air but I
thought like it hit me you know I got so
scared
that was the first time my dolls
disappeared for like five minutes
because I was like man oh my God's gonna
hit me hard you know but
I I needed to get rid of that
and I didn't know how to like there's no
one who's gonna tell me okay do this do
that people can be like no brother you
just have to believe
I mean this is the same thing that the
priests used to tell me when I
questioned Christianity and then and I
went to Catholic uh High School
uh I was not a dumb Christian like I
knew I know the Bible till today and I
knew the Bible back then
and they would say no you have to
believe or don't question so I get the
same like I would go like some imams and
be like no you cannot question you have
to believe I'm like I need to understand
so you don't you're not tall Plus
you kind of left your family right
they're like they already found out they
kind of disappointed and the new
communities so so right come there are
good people but at the same time you
cannot connect to them different culture
right kind of surrounded by a specific
culture
and you're almost forced to convert to
their culture
and they're so confused so it was it was
tough no one told me okay do that and lo
and behold the guys got all the doubts
is the you know the the social worker
for you know the the Islamic Association
dealing with new Muslims you know
helping others so it's like wait a
second what are you doing
but in that war and that struggle
you know you I found purpose wow because
none of this work that I've done would
have been done had it not started with
those doubts and you know actually I
wanted to ask about the Hadith the
prophet maybe this is Maybe This Is The
Answer
um when the uh the sahaba and whom they
approach him they say you know we're
experiencing these huge doubts that if
we believe them that actually lead us to
kufur and the prophet sallam he said
that this is actually really good news
yeah yeah because there's a difference
between
I think questioning something or and
asking a question
um like even you see like Ibrahim right
he's asking Allah like how do you give
life
and Allah
do you not believe
right like Allah is asking do you not
believe
Allah
it's like no I do but just I want my
heart to find
Tranquility wait a second so I I know
some people will like like you're fine
read some fatalities if you have one
doubt you left Islam
like no later it's like no they're out
there and some of these
popular Towers or websites like some of
these brothers have gone on them they
say they've literally kicked themselves
out of Islam we won't name which
websites but you guys might know which
ones we're talking about they're a
little too black and white sometimes
look it's not about that like you just
have to understand
that just because someone gives you a
photo doesn't mean necessarily correct
it's correct exactly yeah like we
respect the scholars of course but of
course they take from these websites you
know but
it's people need to understand like
there's evidence we go based on evidence
not good to just claim that we go you
know okay we follow the Lil but then you
don't follow the lead when it doesn't
suit your direction right yeah there's
no contact there yeah so like Musa is
ask Allah show me yourself same thing
Allah says don't you like what do you
mean you cannot see me don't you believe
like what's wrong
so
you'll find that uh
prophets have sought
yaquin right to have certainty because
they want Allah when the Angels asked
Allah
it's not that they question Allah
like are you gonna put this person on on
Earth it's gonna spill blood and cause
corruption
I know what you don't know I didn't say
how did Dairy question right I said I
don't then after he taught Adam then he
called the angels and he showed them
right what's the benefit of this human
being yes he will spill blood yes he
will cause corruption but there's
so much greater good that's going to
come out
but the angels are learning
the Angels were taught
so um
it's not doubt
but doubt will be there
it's not about
it's it's about
overcoming the doubt
and how you overcome the doubt is
through knowledge
knowledge is is the ilaj the the healing
or the
you know the medicine for for these
doubts and knowing where to take
Knowledge from not just anywhere yeah
and also I think is in the end is your
like do you want it do you want Allah
I don't think
like if someone really wants Allah
they want the truth
then they will be guided I believe this
100 100
and it doesn't matter it's not you don't
want to be guided to what you think is
correct that's a problem in today's
world
that's why Islam is called submission
you submit and the best example again is
like Ibrahimovic imagine bro
he
he's old he's been wanting a son like
you know like every man wants to have a
son bro it's like or a child right
you love it
it's like a little representation of you
you know remember me yes and also your
hopes that whatever failure you've
experienced in life that they want or
they'll succeed at the things you failed
right so much love there
and
Allah tells him
Slaughter your son
no I know people read that I uh you know
we read we don't think sometimes we
don't Ponder
um they think it's a story no it's like
Allah and his dream and we know that the
dreams prophets are Revelation tells
them okay you have to slaughter
so so Ibrahim tells his son what do you
think
so his son his son says do as you are
ordered he didn't say oh it's just a
dream he says do as you are ordered
because he himself is a prophet it's a
son with prophet he knows that this is
revelation you will find me
inshallah
he said that yes you're from the patient
was right he's basically saying
um
so it's like
Slaughter me I was not like putting me
on the wall or give me an injection or
something it's like I'm back take the
knife and cut my throat
you know what I mean yeah
so a lot of people might be disturbed
it's like oh why would God want you to
do something so of course but see that's
the problem
because again it's like I think
I believe this doesn't match
what I believe yeah yeah and and
actually it's a very beautiful segue
into something um it's so important that
I learned this time did not it really
shaped my understanding of Islam you
mentioned before the Christians they say
don't ask just believe don't question
blah blah in Islam you know they
translate Iman as Faith kind of like how
the Christians understand Faith but a
man is not just Faith right Iman
actually linguistically means this is so
beautiful upon Allah Iman linguistically
means the acceptance of a fact and this
ties into this conversation in two ways
one it ties in in the way that we just
spoke about it that it you have to
accept the facts that even you don't
want to accept you know you have to
accept the fact that you don't know you
have to accept the fact that morally
Allah gives what gives us what's
objective and what you heard growing up
and what you believe personally what you
think personally in the grand scheme of
things objectively doesn't actually
matter and that's a hard thing to accept
but once you have Iman in that and you
accept that you can fully submit to
Allah in that way subhanallah and the
other way it ties in when it comes to
amen is linguistically if you think
about it it means acceptance of a fact
meaning that the more you accept the
more you learn the more you accept the
more you manual have over time so
knowledge of Islam knowledge Allah you
have more to believe in about Allah you
have more to understand about Allah from
what he revealed to us the more Iman you
will actually have no no
so
it's um
like people need to understand that
how deep this goes
and
what kind of influence it has on the
person who goes through this
you know and sometimes the even born
Muslims will go through a period of
doubts yeah
100 we don't tear our sins but bro this
is not a linear A to Z ride whatsoever
whoever is yeah it never is it still
isn't sometimes but yeah but I think one
one one one difference that you guys
have uh above Angel and I is that like
your identity is somehow tied to your
faith yeah that is very true and we
don't we forget that the rivers don't
have that yeah it identity starts
something else so we were in the back of
our mind is like I think you guys have
an extra layer of protection yeah as for
us you know it's like man you know
everything is there everything we've
known is there right like even salam
alaikum like that's something new to us
to you even if you leave
stuff online it's like part of your
language and your culture you know what
I mean it's just part of there you know
just an example right that's we have to
learn everything it was nothing really
that that was connected to you know to
our identity from The Deen so I think
it's it's a bit more difficult
so with with new Muslims
they're
there there has to be a specific
approach and I I believe
we don't have it I don't see it anywhere
in the world right now there's some
effort it's better than before 100
but um
with the amount of Converse that we have
or reverts right
that definitely the the Muslim might not
has not done Justice to to new Muslims
now here
we have to be careful though because
sometimes the new Muslims think that
okay because we're new Muslims now the
community always have something that's
not the right way to think about it
um because you also have as Allah says
Allah will test you to see whether
you're truth or not you got to put in
your work no doubt
right but the community has a
responsibility anyway
it's at least some party we should take
care of it and I don't think we're doing
that well some good projects are out
there
alhamdulillah I think you know Ira is
doing some good work with regards to
taking care of new Muslims and I've seen
a very good system in uh in uh in the
college with the Filipino Community
they're doing very good right very very
United
but I think if you look around in the
world like West like North America
um Canada definitely I don't know we're
feeling well so well not so all right so
and one of the
main com uh components of the system is
not only knowledge
but uh the social aspect you know I
think that's where we fail a lot like in
terms of knowledge I think that the
Commerce themselves have to take
responsibility plus there's so many
Avenues right now to learn Islam it's
just everywhere right books courses
online free this that it's real uh but
the social aspect
having that Brotherhood that Sisterhood
is sometimes as important as as seeking
the knowledge well so
because
as human beings we need to belong isn't
it and you've made such a change an
adjustment where you left that community
that was a source of
support
emotional support
and now you have what what do you have
right
um if you don't have anyone you're going
to feel that emptiness
you want to fill it with something
and if you don't that's why many people
go back
to where they came from not because they
had an intellectual doubt because they
didn't have support they will use an
intellectual data as an excuse of course
yes they will no doubt about can you
elaborate on that well for example I had
a friend of mine who subhanallah I mean
will always have such deep discussions
this guy was like first row in fudger
bro in winter like you'd bike in the
winter
like if I get fudgies already there bro
I'm making sticker reading Quran and
like you feel like man I'm so horrible I
think this you know
and he makes you feel bad like a Muslim
brother like he's so much better than
you right
we just have this deep discussions you
say he said bro if I ever leave Islam or
something even just know that it's a lie
like you're so convinced you know you're
so passionate called doubt I'll go to
church but he was coming from a Catholic
background
and
subhanallah it was um
he liked this uh this Mexican girl
you know she was also convert and she
rejected him and I remember subhanallah
like we tried to approach her for
marriage for him you know like he had
the need to
be in love like he felt you know you
need a human being Santa man we need
that
and when she rejected him I well I've
said I sent the change
in his heart something happened and that
I think
um
made him weak and his brother just threw
some curveball at him one day with a
question about cutting the hand right
the head of it which he knew the answer
to and you know we discussed these
things and he would debate people on it
but that time because he was so weak he
had that weakness in him that sadness
that he said
doubt enter into me and he just left
after some a few months
he left Islam I debated him and
discussed him explained to him I said
bro remember what you told me that day
and he was trying no it's not like that
and blah blah
so it's yeah so they'll find an excuse
no doubt but
based on my experience I've worked with
a lot in your muscle growth a lot for
the past almost 20 years
a lot of the problems the reasons are
social or they don't have enough support
and it's it's like sorry how to how to
explain it the social connection support
would allow you to
would
give you the ability to be more focused
on your studies
it's not like this or that it's like
okay
it's the environment it's a nurturing
it's a nurturing that is the environment
is the so it's like imagine you're going
to school walking to school but your
shoes are tight right and they give you
blisters right okay you're going to
school but the whole experience is kind
of messed up or you're sitting on a
chair in class and you're trying to
learn but the chair is very
uncomfortable yeah right it ruins
everything bro right so yeah you're
studying and learning but there's
something irritating it's not working
well there's no flow I think this like
having social support friendship love
care people you can turn to you can talk
to if you have something right that's
like
you know that comfortable chair that
allows you now to sit and be focused and
now absorb the knowledge and grow okay
because people say but look you're
learning but look at that let's learn
but like yeah but you're not comfortable
man like imagine we sit in this podcast
right now
and we're all like I don't know hungry
or something right we're not gonna
yeah
guys okay sorry I literally looked down
I was like 10 minutes
sorry that was a bad example you know
what I mean you're just not able to to
do it properly man
so people are saying look at the books
but the knowledge yeah of course there
is man why did the processor make Hijra
to facilitate a better social
environment for the sahaba so they can
grow in their faith if not they'll just
say no man let's stay Mecca and fight
and this is you know makes us rough and
tough man the process said made Hijra so
the environment will be more conducive
to seek knowledge to grow
to you know people getting married
having families so the community can
grow properly
if not they would have just stayed in
Mecca man so it's so important people
don't realize you know you got people no
man it's just this you got to be strong
no you don't understand the fitra
I think that's a huge component that a
lot of people we haven't been able to
figure I I don't I don't see it anyway
I agree man because when I was you know
when I first became Muslim and I was in
Orlando Florida
um I was by myself for the most part I
had these beautiful Brothers you know
like on online but it was virtual it's
not real it's not like how we are right
now Facebook is different right so when
I was there during this time
um yeah I was growing but it was very
slow progress but then when I went to
North Carolina to stay with my dad for a
little bit
um I remember one of the brothers here
men she's like oh like you should go to
the Muslim I've never been to the Masjid
at the time or I think I had gone once
for Juma and I was like
there was no talking because we had the
mass and everything you know what I'm
saying so I went to the Masjid and then
I ended up you know becoming friends
with like
six seven maybe eight of the brothers
there and just that Community aspect the
progress that I made during that time
and then when I went to Thailand and I
was around like another Muslim brother
pretty much all the time like
that's where the progress came that's
where the change came that's for like
the uh the true cementing of me being a
Muslim game oh no yeah can you can you
go into that a little more the cementing
of you being Muslim yeah so when I was
in North Carolina
um as you know as I was starting to
become friends with these brothers
um I was still you know very new as a
Muslim and I remember one of the
Brothers in the Masjid so this wasn't
part of the group of friends it was just
another brother older brother
um you know may Allah bless him probably
have the best of intention I mean arami
knows this story very well but um
and when he was coming to me he he was
saying a lot of stuff and like I was
hearing your mom because he was saying a
lot of good stuff
but at the time I remember I was reading
a lot of uh Imam and gazelle's work you
know and that was like for me that was
just kind of like opening my mind and
making me feel like more of a Muslim
like wanting to do more as a Muslim
right so it was like facilitating that
for me and when I had mentioned him this
he was basically trying to like throw
everything of Iman I can say like under
the bus like saying that it wasn't worth
it or anything like that that like it
who is to say like him saying that like
that was not very wise yeah it just kind
of it started putting me off and then
like the more he started going off like
saying more things like he started
making more doubts creep up and again
like this probably wasn't his intention
so this is why I say like may Allah
bless him because he he probably did not
intend for this at all but the more
Dallas started creeping in and like
there was even the thought that came
into my head like what are you doing
like why are you even going through this
like look like the thing that was
bringing you closer
to Islam closer to Allah is now like
this this brother over here he's like
refuting it like smashed it just
throwing it all away so it's like oh
should you even be a Muslim should you
even do this and like I remember I like
I took a whole day by myself thinking
that I could do it by myself I get past
it like mentally and like mentally I
just kept going deeper and deeper into
this like pit and I reached out to
Romney and I was like bro like this is
what I'm going through this is what I
feel and I'm having a real tough time
right now and if it wasn't for Rami not
sure like I probably would have I don't
know a lot knows best right
but a lot of people will not reach out
that's the thing a lot of people suffer
in silence and the doubts become bigger
and bigger
right that's why we encourage people if
you have a doubt don't let it grow tall
yeah people of knowledge right yeah of
course talk talk to people talk to
people just or even just talking to
someone just being able to one of the
like in counseling this rule like just
opening up about something it's like 50
of the problems are gone just talk right
and but a lot of people don't feel
because you felt that you could talk to
him you knew that you can approach him
okay
a lot of people
a lot of people don't feel comfortable
to talk to certain Community leaders or
different figures
and
that's part of the problem that we need
to train people understand that new
Muslims
are not like a person who's been born
into Dean has had Muslim family Muslim
culture
you know Muslim identity and then they
say I don't understand what's wrong with
these new Muslims why don't they respect
you know the Masjid or something the guy
doesn't know are you coming with your
tattoos and all that in here don't
respect them as you bro what you don't
know anything what are you talking about
oh you know he's coming in shorts and
whatnot or
you know you need to chill out right but
how do you shut up if you don't talk
about these things in the past you don't
train people you don't
invest
in these kind of projects you know
enough uh chandeliers enough carpets man
enough decorating Masjid we need to
invest in people we have to we need to
build people
and part of building people
being here in an anonymous country
people are going to come to the dean man
you know it's not you like man people
don't even do dawahi in one of our
communities it's like dawah has
disappeared there's no people are still
coming to Islam man you know
people are still entering Islam you're
not even going outside of the Masjid if
you are coming to you what are you doing
you gotta invest enough uh I don't know
what let's change this and let's change
that and let's repaint TVs let's work on
people yeah keep it clean keep it simple
no good but let's work on people let's
build systems train educate
that's what we need oh so I got two
questions for you number one you
mentioned that okay
nourishing your intellectual doubts
at like a cerebral level it didn't
extinguish these little seeds that have
already been planted
so my first question would be how do
people any any new Muslims or anyone
let's say they just reverted you know
and they intellectually get all the
answers but that seed is still there
what is what is your antidote today is
it time is it dwell like you know
because clearly just saying bro just
accept it that's not gonna work
no so you had some say before
how do you know that because I actually
did fall through together yeah yeah the
body language was indicating a
psychologist for you guys
um it's Upon A lot it kind of set my
mind unfortunately um oh yeah actually I
remember Zach luck
so this is really eye-opening for me
what you said to poundland because it
and this is something I think I I have
the mistake of uh making a lot uh I
think people are so focused on on
getting shahadas from people they're not
focused on keeping them and I think it's
something that we can all kind of change
in our mindsets especially myself and
all the duat out there is that getting
the shahada is not really the hard part
it's keeping them and they should really
focus on keeping them Muslim because the
majority unfortunately the statistics
I've seen majority of people who accept
this time actually end up leaving us
over 50 yeah that's our fault the four
of us sitting here and everyone watching
that's our fault we need to facilitate
that and I just want to make it very
clear to everyone that's at home uh
you're a part of it it's not just oh you
know it's our responsibility because
we're up here on a podcast it's your
responsibility as well for because
you're watching it's your responsibility
as well because you know because you're
almost someone who's visibly Muslim who
could go to a river and make their life
easier people love to see the YouTube
shahada say oh yeah Islam is the fastest
growing religion what are you doing now
yeah and people say I don't know how to
give that who said you have to give down
or like you have to not give the like
support the efforts uh support the
projects you can do it with your time
money whatever resources you have you
don't have to be a public speaker or I
don't know I park yeah you know die or
something like that right you just have
to feel the responsibility yeah
and contribute you know and even even
the connection like Angel told the
beautiful story may Allah bless you may
Allah and increase you
um but it was fired that connected us
even that even being a Muslim who can
connect a river to someone that's
knowledge or someone who can help them
that's what you need sometimes man just
connect someone and we could all go
apart everyone together with their part
everyone's got the part but uh education
support
um
it's being able to talk
being able to to grow in a community
to understand to train you know speak
about these things
raise awareness and so on and so forth
there's something very very important
that we don't do we can do much better
inshallah
um everyone was seeing this can support
somehow the dawa and
new Muslims are going to keep coming man
your enter in Islam and groups that's
the
important point is like how many stay
how many can we keep it's not up to us
man Allah guides whom he Wills but what
have we done
we gotta wrap up soon because we gotta
thought about to touch on that point bro
my first question what do you say to
these people bro how did you personally
get over that where it's like you
intellectually had all the answers but
it's just like you couldn't distinguish
that though
it's it was so tough actually like I was
in depression man I was depressed like
that was my second depression in my life
and it was so hard because
coming from a previous depression
Identity Crisis coming into Islam
discovering feeling all power yeah man
the whole camera's here and then that
those doubts started creeping in and the
depression came back
and it's kind of like okay I'm before
everything I knew was wrong identity
crisis then I find Islam I think okay I
found the truth forget about Romania
forget about ethnicity it's the truth so
forget about that you know like
alhamdulillah I love them Romanian no
problem malicious
but
now you've put that aside and the most
important thing in your life is the
truth
now even that it might not be right
like who the heck are you like what's
what is real in this world what is the
truth right bro is such a deep pit that
I went into is crazy and no I wasn't I
was uncomfortable to speak to anyone
like I tried to approach certain people
but the way they reacted
you know I knew I need to test the
waters first
I wasn't comfortable just open up like I
have a problem doubting Islam you know I
just I just opened up a little bit and
then the reaction was like no it's not
working so I had to suffer literally
like about five years bro five years day
in and day out crying sometimes it's
like not telling anyone that I'm dying
you know spiritually and you're lucky
you're researching okay okay this matter
done check right okay why does it not
disappear
okay now you're next not done you know
you're watching more videos you're going
here I was debating some of these guys
man
you look at me you're like no there's
nothing this guy's smashing them right
but inside it was like so intellectual
yes
One Two Three Buck but inside is like
stab stab stab so do you do you feel
that the way they responded and the the
you know the way they responded so
poorly made it worse for you
yeah that's the funny thing is that some
of the questions that I've tried to
bring yeah they didn't even know about
them and they were from Islam itself so
that brought more doubts like wait a
minute Sheikh doesn't know about this
right so that just kind of confirmed the
doubts but
I know Allah kept me like I knew that
okay God exists got a spirit you know
the question was Islam the truth or not
you know what I mean as Islam the truth
or not and um
I think yeah about five years of yeah
intellectual struggle
um spiritual struggle
but to be honest I think in the end
it was the
you know it was the intellectual part
I mean it just went to a point where
like I don't think there was any
question that I didn't cover man I kind
of talked to myself like what are you
doing bro
like
how many more questions you want to
answer until you know that this is the
truth
and that was this epiphany
um well you know what that reminds me of
it's um the one verse where Allah says
that we'll show them the signs yes
exactly outside of them and within
themselves until they see that this the
truth is the truth and and I remember
um obviously like your spiritual
encounters as well now those are
subjective
right but yeah like you'll be like
something like a doubt or a question and
sometimes you open the Quran there's a
versa like you know it's just literally
like tears down bro it's just like it's
like Allah is talking to you know like
straight up and it happens so many times
it's not just a coincidence
you know so I feel I feel of course
Allah will enter will interfere and will
help you but I think he wants to
just
remove any kind of kibber from you any
kind of arrogance just literally sip
humble you to the point you're like I
can't do anything else like a
intellectually I've done everything if
you really want about it I've done
everything I've answered everything
I can't like I need I really need
guidance
and that's why it's brought this many
people intellectually they know Islamic
they don't believe like John Esposito
for example right he knows more Islam
all of us right this is not a Muslim
it's not it's not enough to to have that
right there's so many orientals who know
Islam literally more better than all of
us they're not believers they don't
believe and I remember reading one of
these uh
these orientalists
and he's like saying I was in Egypt
Somewhere listening at Ramadan to the
recitation of that and he understands
Arabic like these guys would speak
Arabic you're talking about when you
deal with orientists but it's a
different ballgame
uh Montgomery watt you know Sir William
you're all of them
and like he's saying that I'm sitting on
the balcony listening to the recitation
of the Sheikh and his understanding
right and he's like
he's talking to himself like he himself
is doubting whether he's on the right
path or not you know like he said the
Quran is just pulling me
you know it's just
but
in his mind he's just he knows he can he
can understand imagine bro being able to
understand what the Imam is reciting and
he's not a Muslim
right and um no I'm going bro but
where's the guidance and he's he feels
it he's inclined towards it but there's
an arrogance to stop him because he's on
a mission to show that Islam is wrong
now many people have started that way
ended up being very good Muslims
um
however
not everyone right again can you say
what's the ingredient let's I think it's
sincere how do you strip that arrogance
and get the sincerity
in the class I think you just like one
thing that I can say that I've done and
again is by the blessing Allah I didn't
give up I wanted to go so many times bro
I could have given up I could just moved
somewhere no one knows me
I mean life was as a non-muslim I was
balling man because really and have a
good time you know literally bro life is
good
but I loved God man
I really even as a non-muslim I always
loved God man I was like I needed to and
I knew him Islam was like I know God
exists I love God and I know there's
only one way there's just no it doesn't
make sense man that God would just
confuse you and stuff like that the
problem is
with most all these guys shamoons and
woods and all these videos that they
keep pumping every you know two minutes
or whatever they do without their
you know with all their support and
whatever
in the end bro
Islam is submission
right all these guys do what they do
because they believe they are right it's
not that they believe that Islam is
wrong because they believe that they are
right
and that's the wrong mindset with a lot
of Muslims too they think that the truth
has to be something that they agree with
whoa whoa say that one more time bro
that's what they'll say it's only like
oh that makes sense to me excuse me what
do you mean it makes sense to you who
are you the truth has to be something
that I agree with somehow that's what it
is but mostly If we're honest enough
with ourselves even us bro like a lot of
times the the value of Truth is
literally like does it really fit with
the the schemat or the schema that I
have in myself
so there's an external schema an
internal right so how do you which one
do you adjust your internal or the
external one right most of the time
we'll adjust the external one to fit our
predisposed you know ideas
so but that's why Islam is submission
because in the end you gotta like allow
put you on your knees bro
and literally I was like Almighty I was
like I can't do anything anymore like I
was depressed I was crying you know uh
Institute like
and it was like
I can't do more than this man I mean
I've written like 200 articles done all
these videos I respond to everything and
still
why don't I have Iman why don't I have
yaquin at least I mean where yakin is
the highest but like why don't I have
Iman bro like why don't I feel like why
doesn't my heart feel
at rest
right it was because I was probably
still trying to in my attempt okay you
can answer one question that's one of my
advice to many of the new Muslims you
can answer one two three four five
at the end realize that that's it man
like it's enough you don't have to
answer 200 because you realize look it's
a pattern and one of the things that
really got me was that these people are
always using different translations of
the Quran to fit their argument a lot of
people don't notice that but I remember
making that realization and I was like
oh wait a sec
I was like wait a second how come you're
using this this translation and this the
other transition
right that was huge thing another thing
that helped me with regards to knowledge
was when I was able to read Arabic and
understand Arabic like the Arabic
language is so important bro
so important because it just it was
different man
but a lot of people even make this I
want to cut you out but they also make
this argument that the thing about
Arabic you said like Islam is not a
universalized religion it's not because
why did Allah choose Arabic it's not
about that bro it's like uh I don't know
it's it's not that it's it's not that
it's not a universal religion right it's
for everyone it's for any time ever any
place but they're able to understand
what it is Allah did reveal in Arabic so
then you go to the verse in Quran Allah
says what the verse you quoted before if
you don't know go to those who know just
ask the the David wood gave this verse
he gave this this translation
um is this accurate let him translate it
for you he'll break down every word
and so on and so forth uh see that's a
very irrational argument because had had
it been in English people were like not
doubt it before do I mean right because
why because that's like
English is like lingua Franca right
everyone speaks English I mean even like
the Japanese wouldn't make an argument
like oh why is it in like they don't do
that right
it's just they don't
because English is just at that time
Arabic was was powerful and even if
let's say that's not a good argument
it's the modality of seeking the
knowledge the means through it it's just
the means be it Arabic or Chinese or
whatever it is it's just a language
it's not that's not the most important
thing even though it's it helps
but it's the the knowledge behind it the
depth
that the code I can imagine trying to
understand
um
physics through I don't know art oh it
makes no sense yeah most Muslims are not
even Arab bro how do you understand
physics through mathematics yeah that's
the language man and people will be like
you know oh it's not fair we should
understand it through biology you know
it's not like that man you know so it
doesn't make sense it's again it shows
how arrogant some people are yeah right
come on man you picking Arabic it's like
whatever it's just a language yeah right
yeah I do with my last question let me
see I just just add one more point also
Arabic does a very good job of of
delivering the message imagine trying to
deliver in English you'd have 20 more
David Woods no doubt no doubt I mean and
that argument can be made of course that
is the depth of the languages
people you know argue it and so it
doesn't matter your point doesn't stand
it's just the language okay look beyond
that look how what it brings to the
information that it brings to you right
I mean initially we wanted to start this
episode truly be told about you know a
couple of the most common doubts that
new rivers and Muslims have such as you
know polygeny age
you name it bro all these things you can
find online we will link it in the
description inshallah we'll make an
episode maybe we won't I don't know but
I do want to wrap this up with the last
question inshallah because this was very
conducive nonetheless
what advice do you have to New Rivers
new Muslims that are maybe going through
this or maybe they're not maybe they're
they're running on that Midnight Oil bro
that convert Zeo they're on cloud nine
they're like
they're good you know and they think
that they're gonna be this High forever
um be as humble as possible
you know be as humble as possible when
you enter the faith
um seek as much knowledge as possible
and
pick a few friends that are around you
they feel comfortable to talk to if you
have issues like have a Social Circle
and don't give up don't don't ever give
up you know develop your Iman through
these ways especially knowledge of
course right
but have that comfortable
environment that social protection have
some one of the one of the best things
that I mean I was surrounded by good
Brothers man and I will never forget
them you know I don't know if they're
watching this or not but I remember the
names give them a shout out bro yeah
give a shout out to Assad to Harris to
Ahmed to Usman to Muji to sophian oh my
God to
so many others and to all the ones that
were unnamed right now don't think we
forgot you we see you exactly I said to
all the ones that we didn't name yeah we
did a name listen come on man like this
is right like he was always there for me
and you know and I'm here all the
brothers man and the Masjid like that
was a big thing I was blessed by Allah
to have that support yeah I was going
through doubts but you know just
hanging out with the brothers
going to eat
talking just really really really really
helped
and had I not had that I don't know what
would have happened you know so yeah
that's why you see yeah
what's an um
I used to always wonder that I was like
and I I don't listen guys anyone
watching this Christian listen we we
disagree with Christian theology it
doesn't mean we hate Christians or
anything like that we don't we don't
have any type of discrimination or
anything like that so when I say this I
want you all to
really look into what I'm saying in
terms of context but
I look at Christians sometimes and I'm
just like bro the Trinity makes no sense
it's literally it's just nonsensical in
my opinion right but it's okay to have
different opinions
but I look at how devoted they are oh
they are I look at how much of a
community they have sometimes they do
and I look at like how sometimes
sometimes four people by and large
having a nonsensical ideology
but a strong community
yields more conviction than having a
sensical ideology but you're the only
one there you get me and a lot of
Muslims don't understand this bro
subhanallah like even like me and Donald
bro we were passing by these these these
Freemason uh associations
every time we drive bro they got one
door and then they go another door right
behind that bro just added protection no
one's no one's looking through but I
don't know I think you got that
Community the community is really
important yeah right so at the end of
the day I used to always wonder I was
like bro if only they just realized bro
the Trinity doesn't make sense if only
XYZ religion you know these people they
just realize like it doesn't make sense
but it's like bro they have that
Community they have that blanket they
have that they have that reassurance
that reinforcement so maybe they don't
need to ask these questions
whereas someone who has the truth but
they might not have anyone else on their
side they might be really asking these
questions bro so yeah and the last but
not least
stay off YouTube man all these weird
videos you gotta be smart like no
I don't have the mentality well wait if
I'm on the truth I should be able to
answer all these questions and you have
an ad there you can
there you go cancel you know you're
canceled like that that's not how it
works
just because you're on the truth that
does that mean you're going to know how
to answer all the questions man like
you're putting yourself
you're jumping into fire like any person
knows we're like wait a second
you haven't trained for like three
months yeah you're gonna jump in the
ring with like guy who's been training
twice a day
no but I've trained I know how to fight
yeah you know how to fight you're gonna
kick your back man you know send to the
hospital like it doesn't make sense that
you would even put yourself no I gotta
prove myself I got heart I'm not so you
don't have heart I don't I'm not seeing
another fight I'm saying you're not
ready it's like a first grader trying to
take like the SATs just to be like let
me see how smart I am yeah listen well
like bro this is a personal thing I came
across these YouTubers and they gave me
major doubts but it's it's because I
didn't have the foundation bro and I I
recommend anyone whether it's in a you
know the war like a battle strategy type
scenario intellectual thing anything
know that enemy know exactly how they
think know how that works but you gotta
be firmly rooted in your own side first
a lot of people they don't they don't
water their own garden and they're out
here concerned about you know the other
people and bro where do you think that's
going to lead yeah it's not bro the
other night Romney was alive on Tick
Tock Marshall and I come downstairs
and uh me and him just joined us and
then it became like the two to TM 2tm on
his Tick Tock and um this one brother
was uh talking to us on there like you
can add people on the stream right and
um he he got on there and he was trying
to basically ask about
um what was he asking about you're
talking about the guy that was like my
mom's behind yeah yeah yeah yeah and he
was he basically didn't want to talk to
certain people or see certain things
because he knew they were going to
change his mind yeah and I and then it's
like me and Mommy were like well why are
you talking to yeah are you talking
around me you know and Romney you tell
the story bro
I'm sorry uh long story short he um hey
he came and he's kind of playing the
half half game he's I think he was
sincere but he's like I came from a
Baha'i family but I'm really pulled to
Christianity and then he's asking all
these things about Islam right and he's
like it's not condescending it's almost
condescending but I could tell he's also
sincere it's like it's almost as if he
came on to try and improve Christianity
is true by disproving Islam yeah through
us but unfortunately for him well very
fortunate for him actually alhamdulillah
he came to to see that that was that
wasn't that case right it was not the
case he was pulled further away from
Christianity a little closer to Islam
alhamdulillah and by the end we can hear
him type him on his keyboard like he's
looking things up and and then he parted
ways bro and he was um
he was trying to like say that you know
Jesus
was basically saying this in the Bible
and then uh Rami was like whoa in what
basis do you have with that you know
because the Bible is altered so you
can't really trust what's being said in
there and then we brought out this book
right there let me grab it
me basically says like what could be
true what was true and what we have no
idea
is editor zoom in on this
um but let me open it up and show them
how it works all right so the five
gospels is a book by the uh the Jesus
seminar and a few other New Testament
Scholars they put in Red Letters things
that Jesus most likely said they put in
pink letters things he probably said but
it's not as likely as it read they put
in Gray letters things he probably
didn't say and they put in big bold
black letters things he definitely did
not say and if you were to flip through
the book you'd find mostly 95 big bold
black letters yeah and this is from the
five gospels yeah the five gospels and
the Christian before you jump on me I
know you don't think the Gospel of
Thomas is canonical but some historians
still accept it as a historical piece of
documentation so they put it in here
yeah but anyways he was saying that and
he was um he was trying to say that like
what Jesus said in the Bible was true
and then I asked someone was like bro
like have you read the Bible
and he hadn't even read the entire Bible
yet and then I brought up to him because
he was trying to like bring up the point
of how like the Trinity was real
and he like as he was saying the example
of the Trinity bro he just mixed it he's
like oh
you know what let me stop because I
forgot what I was gonna say and that's
when I was like bro
it's really confusing in in I think it
was on Mark I forgot the chapter but in
one of the chapters one of the you know
the it's not the Aya because it's not
the Quran verses yeah the verse in the
verse Jesus says
um when he's asked about the the final
hour he says that only with the father
like I don't know this and then when I
told him that he's like where is that
and I told him the exact chapter and
when he he got the chapter he read it
out loud and it's just like man like
some people man like
for real I don't want to stray too much
because everything always leads to these
damn Christians bro but we have love for
the Christian Community and we have so
much love that not only do we just keep
our mouth shut we have something to say
because we want y'all to open your eyes
and it's a it's a very gentle reminder
to ourselves too as Muslims to know your
religion too you know everyone knows I
was I was talking with Angelo a couple
days ago and I want to end on this point
we have a friend that's kind of
struggling with Islam right and we were
talking about him and and kind of you
know what they can do and all this and
this one time I picked up the Quran you
know when we were talking and I picked
up the Quran and subhanallah you know
how you talk about these spiritual you
know encounters and experiences the
first art that came to me
I forgot which suit I was but it
literally said Allah says all believers
do you not realize that if I had wanted
to I could have made everyone a Believer
sure if I really wanted to I could have
easily made everyone a Muslim no yeah
and with that being said
that was very that was very sexual bro
it was
all right bro and with that being said
guys if you want to support the dawa
inshallah links in the description for
Gabriel Romani support the dial support
the movement he's doing wonderful work
Insha'Allah subscribe like comment share
with Deacon and if you know a new River
or an Old River or just any new River
new Muslim anyone struggling with Islam
going through their ups and downs which
is normal send them this video
Insha'Allah and stay tuned inshallah for
more episodes uh next episode is does
size matter if you think I'm joking if
you think I'm joking just wait all right
you're gonna see what I'm talking about
and with that being said Allah
boom